[Music]
that's chris bowers on stage
playing alongside scenes from the
acclaimed netflix miniseries
when they see us it's just one of the
many projects that the composer has
worked on
blockbuster movies hit tv shows
documentaries and even
a video game bowers has composed and
scored it all
oh and did we mention he's just 32 years
old
i spoke with him about his journey at
the colburn school in downtown los
angeles the same place where he took
music classes
growing up
you can't see chris bowers in this scene
or this one but you can hear him
i don't know if people know that many
film composing names outside of the
industry to be honest i feel like maybe
one or two
yeah one or two yeah let's name them
john williams
and quincy jones baby yeah yeah what
were you going to say can i add chris
bowers to the list sure yeah i'll take
that
bowers musical journey began 32 years
ago
before he was even alive my dad
told me the other day i didn't even
realize the story but he said he was
driving in the car and heard some piano
music and got really emotional and my
dad is
that's very far from who my dad is and
he said he came home that night and told
my mom that they had to have a son and
he was going to play piano and they put
piano music in my mom's stomach and then
from the time i was born
set out to find the best education for
me and find a way to make it happen
born and raised in los angeles
he started piano lessons at age four
it didn't take long to see and hear that
there was something special there
while it was classical that brought him
in
it was another sound that made him stay
it wasn't until i found jazz and
improvisation that all of a sudden it
was my thing all of a sudden it was like
oh i'm expressing myself i'm like
coming up with stuff i'm writing my own
music
and then especially being an introvert
but also a pretty emotional
kid i feel like now i can put any
moments that i'm really
sad or mad or any of those things into
the piano and i felt like it was
a release and a meditative thing that i
didn't realize until much later
[Music]
[Applause]
in 2006 bowers went off to juilliard
the only jazz pianist enrolled that year
please say hello to chris bowers
in 2011 something else happened
he won the prestigious thelonious monk
jazz piano competition
[Music]
leading to a record deal and a huge fan
do my set and i come off stage and as
i'm still trying to shake off the nerve
somebody's like
hey somebody wants to meet you out front
do you mind
and as i'm walking to the front they're
like by the way it's aretha franklin
you're about to meet
and i'd never been speechless really
before meeting anybody
and i just was like i'm such a fan i'm
such a fan
i'm such a fan i just kept repeating
myself it's like do you really know what
to say
[Music]
aretha's publicist became bowers first
manager
launching his composing career
the 2013 documentary elaine stritch
shoot me okay was his debut
he was only 29 years old green book
when he composed 2019's best picture
winner
green book ladies and gentlemen please
welcome the don
shirley trio bowers may not have been
seated at the piano
that's him standing nearby but his hands
were on the keys
he wanted somebody that could teach
marshall the piano one more time one
more time possibly play piano for him
and also score the film
he wouldn't have to wait long to be back
at the oscars
this time nominated as co-director for
this year's best short documentary
a concerto is a conversation
a 13-minute tribute to his grandfather
and the dry-cleaning business he built
in the face of adversity
in south central los angeles people are
constantly throwing up things to stop
you
in life one of the biggest things was
really putting into
context the time and the age in which he
did that
and looking at what he was doing at 21
years old or 22 years old like starting
this business and a family and all of
that
being a black man at that time i feel
like it made me feel
even more thankful for like not only
what he did but also the fact that i
don't have to deal with
nearly the level what he's dealing with
enter bridgerton
the most watched show in netflix history
it's also the project for which he just
received
two emmy knots
once we found the sound of the show we
found some of our themes then
i was able to really focus on how to
take those themes throughout the season
and look at how the characters are
moving throughout their relationships
and everything
chris bauer's legacy grew even bigger
this month
everything in between these four lines
is work
with this summer's blockbuster sequel
space jam a new legacy
composed during covet
studying the old looney tunes studying
how they write if we're going out
we're going out loony really once i
dove deep into that i feel like i was i
felt a little bit more comfortable about
trying to figure out my version of that
for this film
these days bowers is working on the
second season of bridgeton
and several other projects on the
horizon
you've done it all you told deadline i
feel like the luckiest man
alive do you still feel that way
yeah for sure yeah i feel like i get to
do this every day as my as my job
you know get to explore like the meaning
of life through music i feel like it's
pretty
pretty amazing yeah
[Music]
did i mention he's a nice guy wow really
nice guy well you know he has a resume
of a 60 year old and
it just doesn't stop i mean he's working
on the biopic
he worked on respect the biopic on
aretha franklin who
full circle moment she helped get into
the business of this
and also uh king richard the the father
of uh venus and serena williams that
that movie that that'll be an issue yeah
so a lot going on and he just got
married folks
wow a lot going on yeah a lot to see
really good stuff nice job michelle
thank you jack saw space jam at the
drive-in you love it i know it's gotten
some mixed reviews but he said it was
amazing
okay i'll ask him about the music now
yep